haremos la siguiente suma 7 puntos 0 56
600 5.7 más 5 puntos 67 cuando sumamos
números queremos asegurarnos de que
estén alineados especialmente cuando
sumamos decimales y la forma más fácil
de hacerlo es alineando el punto decimal
hagámoslo así que tenemos 7 puntos 0 56
más 600 5.7 más 5 puntos 67
y ahora tenemos todo alineado todas las
unidades las tenemos en la posición de
las unidades las décimas las tenemos
alineadas en la posición de las décimas
así como las centésimas y milésimas así
que podemos sumar vamos a iniciar por la
posición de las milésimas esta es la
posición de las décimas centésimas y
milésimas
este número es literalmente seis
milésimas y lo vamos a sumar con las
otras milésimas en este caso no hay
milésimas y podemos hacerlo de dos
maneras
simplemente bajar este seis o podemos
ver este número 600 5.7 como 600 5.700
podemos agregar ceros a la derecha de
este 7 de este decimal como sea
necesario sin cambiar el valor podemos
hacer lo mismo aquí 5.670 y así 600 es
igual a 6 y podemos continuar 50 + 7 es
igual a 12 escribimos 2 en la posición
de la
décimas y llevamos 110 es igual a 17 es
igual a 86 es igual a 14 ponemos el 4 y
nos llevamos 1 hacia la columna de las
unidades así es que ahora tenemos 17 es
igual a 88 5 es igual a 13 13 5 es igual
a 18 y llevamos 1 hacia la siguiente
columna que es la de las decenas 10 es
igual a 1 y entonces este 6 bajará
directamente porque ya no tenemos nada
más que sumar en la posición de las
centenas y no olvidemos el punto y así
cuando sumamos estos números el
resultado es 600 18.426 o 600 18.426
milésimas y hemos terminado